LOCKWOOD: Yes-- I'm sorry--
STUDENT: It's written.
00:00:21.000-00:00:25.000
Thank you for speaking to us.
00:00:23.000-00:00:31.000
What you're saying seems to depend on an idea of order,
00:00:31.000-00:00:35.000
and order between members of a community
00:00:35.000-00:00:39.000
and an order between a community and god.
00:00:39.000-00:00:43.000
I was wondering-- and it seems like your idea of
00:00:43.000-00:00:45.000
focusing only on objective rights
00:00:45.000-00:00:48.000
is also to kind of ensure that a community can
00:00:48.000-00:00:51.000
remain itself even when it
00:00:51.000-00:00:53.000
interacts with other communities.
00:00:53.000-00:00:56.000
But in a situation where two communities come
00:00:56.000-00:00:59.000
together, and they have to reorder within themselves
00:00:59.000-00:01:04.000
and some of the rights that they see as objective
00:01:04.000-00:01:09.000
differ, what happens? What
00:01:09.000-00:01:11.000
approach would Christianity take to
00:01:11.000-00:01:14.000
this situation? What
00:01:14.000-00:01:18.000
would you-- what's the result?
LOCKWOOD: That-- it seems to me
there are no--
there are no quick fixes in the political realm. That is to say, in a sense I can't answer
your question because I don't know.
What would happen would entirely depend on
the-- whether one was
a very much minority community, whether they were more or less equal,
you know, in their population
so that there had to be a-- I mean, I assume you are now talking about a
political situation, because there would be
no other reason why they would have
to,
as it were-- as their right--
that their
conceptions of objective goods would be endangered by--
by other communities. Is that right? Have I got that--
STUDENT: Yes, but if it's political and--
LOCKWOOD: Yes--
STUDENT: --the political arises from the social, and so--
LOCKWOOD: Oh know that, but
how do they do live together in the political society is the--
and so
I just wanted to--that was just a clarification
of what you were getting at.
So I would go back to
"I don't know."
If the two communities were perhaps about
equal in population, they
might have to
have somewhat different legal systems.
There might be-- as, for instance, I think
has been the case but is progresively
less so in India,
accommodating
different communities.
At certain levels
you know, so if
it's a federal system, then
where different community laws are
affected would
depend on the
level which these
problems arise.
The-- there is a common good
that in the political society--
if it wants to stay together as political
society-- there is a common political good
which is going to
require
a rather delicate
negotiation
of communal goods.
When it's a matter of
a small minority,
they may well be protected
as much as possible
within
public law
in terms of the
internal workings of the community but not
have
public representation.
I'm speaking now very much as a person from
the British isles, where some
religious institutions do have
public representation and others don't.
Different political systems handle that
differently, but do you see
the point, in a sense, I'm making in
relation to your question, that
there is--
there is no one way
of handling it,
but i think that what I would call the ideology
of egalitarian rights, in which all
individuals and all communities have be treated--
treated equally
to be respected equally
is--
is in many societies not on,
and not a good idea, and doesn't actually
serve the common good.